qui s'est attaqué pas un animal renée
marie toi vous hasard ynwa à oui je me
suis amusé avec loi que de sympathiques
mais en fait le jard était très le jaf
son mari et mes très chers et jean
michaud piste agressif il est arrivé de
derrière c'est énorme c'est que ça et
après mais savez-vous et après alors
avec des grandes ailes et tout ça va
vite parce que ça fait des sauts il ma
faim si le mollet un marais salés france
non c'était pas cuba qui donnait pas
rater le volet ouais c'était le noir
oui ça fait un mal de malades non c'est
très dangereux
c'est très dur très bon jour je
maintenant je sais pas beaucoup de gens
que mais ça va seulement genre ça joue
sur un animal tu sais que j'aime les
animaux
à ce train là bas très bien des rats des
rats c'était pas des rapts at oui mais
sur le jardin et du panel doha à paris
c'est vrai que c'est un fait cédric
ouattara que toi ah oui mais il y avait
des détritus un peu partout où ils sont
passés dans les mains d'un homme et dans
mes jambes et alors mais c'est pas ta
sur foot et on tape agrément kader après
on dit on à bercy ont gagné de
service-volée mais on t'a vu un rat un
os de une à une dizaine ont ravi la
bulle orages
oui vous êtes très inquiet parti lui est
fatale
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu peux attaquer par un taureau away et
les taureaux mois on m'avait dit mais tu
sais ça risquerait rien ils vont
traverser le champ et sa vaisselle et le
tour mais n'a pas eu le temps de lui
demander son mal j'avais 7 ans d'accord
mais riant
la tour où tu as déjà c'est la première
chose
la première fois de ma vie que ce sens
le sol bouger comme ça parce que
l'animal faisait plusieurs centaines de
kilos inscrits c'est la première fois
aussi que je vois des basques au
cambodge on voit tous les jours ici
c'est bon là voilà les ai roulé j'ai
roulé sous des barbelés alors assisté au
moment où il passait donc avec la corne
il m'a arraché ma chaussure merde
aujourd'hui sur le bon coin et depuis ça
s'est toujours fait un détour par les
cornes et s'attaquer parfois avoir des
fourmis rouges par des fourmis rouges
ah oui mais je vous dis aimez chanter ça
non mais les fourmis rouges moi je sais
mais j'étais nue non mais cabaye
habiller les fourmis rouges je ne sens
pas alors c'est quoi l'histoire c'est
que j'ai était bronzé et la mode arrive
j'étais l'accompagnent dont sur l'herbe
en fait la mode venez pas avoir de
marquer là-bas évidemment j'avais des
marques de maillots et un bon du coup je
me suis fait bronzer que la par les
parties et j'avais mis de l'huile de
monoï entre la plus sacrée lancés la
peau la plus fine
michel sidobre
si mon attaque tellement attaqué et
malheureusement la mla l'époque n'était
pas non plus à l'épilation donc elles se
sont foutus caché à l'intérieur de la
forêt et je voulais retrouver la forêt
brûlent la poison pour les gt brut
s'étaient attaqués il ya des coiffeurs
pu bien fait t'es pas obligé de tu crois
qu'à la campagne va taper sur google
quoi par pina mais t'es con quoi
impossible pour amir khadir et font des
permanents la dernière fois ils m'ont
mis des déconfite
[Applaudissements]
je
[Rires]
à luchon bah moi je suis allée du
camping sauvage non oui et jeté dans le
matin et en fait en pleine nuit je me
suis réveillé pour une envie pressante
et j'étais chargé par un sanglier
non avec sa progéniture well essangui
déteste être vu avec sa progéniture il a
peur il a pris peur et il m'a chargé et
j'ai super peur donc j'ai couru nu ah ça
c'est ce qu'il faut faire dans la
montagne et j'ai créé un éboulement
non non et non qu'ils reprennent après
tanguay parti et moi je me suis retrouvé
nu au milieu de la de la montagne cela
était tranquillement aux parties furent
pipi ou 3 elle a créé un drame je suis
heureux je n'ai pas chien sur la pelouse
accroc et vous apprendra qu'un poil
tacle un poulpe ou un parent peut que
jouer juste devant chez elle met la main
dans un dans un trou qui met le prouver
c'est sympa c'est parce que je suis con
et je reconnais témoignages un vrai
témoignage est en fait j'ai mis la main
il s'est entouré sur tout le monde j'ai
sorti la la la la main en fait ça ne se
détache paille dans l'oeil il faut le
tuer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous savez vincent jamais été attaqué
par un animal c'est de me faire attaquer
j'ai dû attaquer un animal un animal
j'adore les animaux vous dire moi tu
veux même pas d'animal qui m'attaque je
sais lui parler ouais je vais lui dire
non on a mis sa vie épargne ou s'est dit
beaucoup du monde
[Rires]